[Applaudissements]
bonjour aussi à toute heure merci d'être
là aujourd'hui je m'appelle à l'export
oui
aujourd'hui j'aimerais que vous me
laissez vous transporter dans un bateau
ce bateau là qui porte mon histoire
c'est celle d'un jeune garçon né au
cameroun d'un père à l'époque bande à
tchô suire et d'une mère ménagère
c'est celle d'un jeune garçon qui
aujourd'hui et scientifiques ingénieurs
mais qui tout jeune marché des
vingtaines de minutes pour trouver un
point d'eau
pour la plupart des personnes dans la
salle vous aviez ou avis certainement
des rêves et bien sachez que le mien
quand j'étais tout jeune c'était d'être
un grand ingénieur celui là dont
l'activité aurait des répercussions
positives dans la vie d'autrui
l'ingénieur que je voulais être rêvait
de rejoindre sa famille en europe afin
de poursuivre sa formation
loin de moi l'idée de discréditer toute
institution africaine et plus encore
toucher du doigt la culture noire
américaine pour moi cela relevait du
miracle
pour ceux qui ignorent où se situe le
cameroun n'a c'est un pays situé en
afrique centrale limité sur la côte
ouest par l'océan atlantique et le
nigeria
déjà tout jeune à l'âge de 10 ans à peu
près comme vous le voir sur la photo de
gauche
mais matinée en général étaient
similaires comme un rituel je me lever
très tôt autour de cinq heures pour
éviter les longs rangs je marchais
environ une vingtaine de minutes à la
recherche d'un point d'eau après avoir
fait plusieurs tours de la sorte c'est
le moment de me préparer pour aller en
cours je dois vous dire que le parcours
pour rejoindre l'établissement était
digne de formation d'un viking en effet
il fallait passer en bordure de dur
avant l'un après l'autre ensuite marcher
sous un pont de la bri en essayant de
garder son équilibre ou quelqu'un je me
retrouverai en train de prendre une
deuxième douche ou pire encore je
pourrais me faire porter par les bacs
les jours de fortes pluies
alors je vous laisse imaginer les
pensées obscures qui me parcourait la
tête chaque jour je vous laisse imaginer
les mêmes frissons qui me parcourt l apo
chaque jour et si je me retrouvais au
fond de ce ravin et si je me fais
emporté par ses bagues
quand sera le tube de mois qu'en
sera-t-il de mes rêves
qu'ils seraient là pour les réaliser
c'est alors qu'après mes cours en
général je faisais du commerce des
marchandises que ma mère faisait au feu
de bois
les samedis les dimanches j'allais
travailler dans des chantiers comme
ouvriers
et les mois de juillet août c'étaient
les travaux champêtres façon générale la
semence et de la récolte
c'est vrai j'ai grandi dans un
environnement précaire autour de moi il
y avait des personnes qui vivaient pire
que cela
certains disent que la risée et pour
d'autres qui étaient scolarisés ils
finissaient soient pas abandonnées en
cours de chemin ou pas revoir leurs
rêves les glisse entre les doigts cela
pour faute de moyens ou sinon à cause
des difficultés que la ville a imposé
voyons tout ce loto de moi j'avais
décidé de travailler dur afin d'avoir un
avenir meilleur que celui que j'avais à
cet instant de ma vie c'est ainsi que
j'ai réussi à finir mon lycée et que
j'étais excité à l'idée de rejoindre
l'université
je voudrais tout de même rajouté qu à
cette époque de ma vie je n'étais pas
public avec la plus grande estime de sa
personne
alors je me rappelle
durant notre durant ma première année
d'université nous avions un projet de
groupe et à la fin de ce projet il
fallait remettre un rapport
dans mon groupe nous étions 16 je vous
laisse imaginer l'effet de masse chacun
se disait on est assez nombreux dans
forcément quelqu'un quelqu'une finira
par faire le devoir
c'est ainsi que par effet papillon je me
suis retrouvé seul à devoir faire ce
devoir
vous imaginez la solitude d'un côté et
de l'autre côté une faible confiance à
soi c'est pas du tout le bon match
mais pour moi l'idée d'avoir zéro
n'était plus une alternative
c'est la raison pour laquelle j'ai
travaillé et à l'aide de la bibliothèque
de l'époque que nous avions une boutique
avec des versions de papiers pas de
version numérique j'ai réussi à mettre
sur pied un rapport que j'ai remis aux
profs et là je me suis dit ah jones qui
adviennent
à la remise des notes nous avait un
autre de 17 souvent ce qui équivaut à
peu près à plus
tout le monde à mon groupe de tête joie
était tous contents c'est vrai j'étais
aussi très content mais ce que j'ai
surtout ressenti en ce moment c'est mon
estime personnelle que j'ai dû booster
j'avais l'impression que j'étais capable
j'avais du potentiel mais aussi j'avais
pris de goût à la recherche
d'informations
c'est donc depuis lors que je me suis
mis au travail que j'ai réussi avant le
baccalauréat et que là au moment de
commencer mes études de maîtrise je me
suis tourné dans mon oncle mon deuxième
père paix à son âme décidé aujourd'hui
un an
je lui ai manifesté mon désir de vouloir
aller à l'étranger pour suivre ma
formation il sait dominer s'est arraché
afin que je puisse émigré en france que
je puisse avoir un dormir et que je
puisse être scolarisés
me voilà dans en france à l'université
paris-sud
premier jour jour de l'inscription
pédagogique
j'arrive devant ce grand bâtiment
où se trouvait le bureau de la scolarité
à l'avant on pouvait se voir tapisser le
long de grands escaliers ces pics de
ceux d'un musée limité sur les côtés par
des petits abuse très bien taillée
entretenu
dès que vous entriez on pouvait voir
tout le long les cases hiver typique de
ceux des films que je voyais quand
j'étais au cameroun là je me suis dit
tiens je suis en france on rêve devient
réalité
je me dirige donc vers le bureau de la
scolarité proprement dit et là une
vitrine transparente mais ses parts
d'albert aux abeilles
cet homme charismatique
dans la prestance ne laisse rien à ready
quant à la crédibilité de tout ce qu'il
peut vous dire
allonger dit albert que je suis là pour
m'inscrire en triste physique
fondamentale
albert me pose la question si je suis
bien certain que j'ai été admis dans ce
parcours
je confirme albert lui j'ai été admis
dans le parcours maîtrise physique
fondamentale et je suis là pour faire
mon inscription pédagogique
sauf qu albert me repose la question et
laisse transparaître la difficulté de la
maîtrise mais aussi des doutes quant à
la capacité de pouvoir réussir ce
parcours
alors tout à coup je me suis sentis
bouleversés
je vis mon estime personnelle remis en
question je me suis demandé si j'avais
bien fait d'être admis dans ce parcours
est ce que j'étais au bon endroit
je me suis retrouvé tout à coup à
nouveau au bord de ce ravin
à me demander est ce que cette fois ci
je vais me retrouver au fond
je me suis retrouvé également sur ce
même pont de la bri
à me dire est ce que cette fois ci je me
fais remporté par les bagues
mes rêves prendre dans fin
par la même occasion je me suis rappelé
les
douves à ce que je viens je me suis
rappelé sur pourquoi je me battais pour
ce rêve que je voulais atteindre
est ce que je voulais retourner ce petit
garçon apeurés non j'ai donc confine
albert que je suis bien là pour
m'inscrire en physique fondamentale
voilà que deux mois se sont écoulés
je suis quasi inexistant dans ma salle
de classe je n'arrive à parler à
personne
quasiment personne ne m'adresse la
parole est pire encore pendant les cours
que je comprends pas je n'arrive pas
posé de questions du fait de la barrière
de l'accent
je me sentais dont frustré
isolé j'avais l'impression d'être au
mauvais endroit
je n'avais qu'une envie retourner parmi
les miens parmi ces où j'avais
l'impression d'être écoutés d'avoir un
sentiment d'existence je voulais
retourner d'où ils venaient
mais je pense et par la même occasion à
tous ces efforts que des membres de ma
famille ont fait
certains qui sont privés de leur propre
plaisir pour me soutenir mois dans la
tête de mes rêves
je me suis raciste je me suis rappelé
delà de ça et je me suis dit si
j'abandonne là c'est qu'on piétine et
tous ces efforts là et puis j'avais ce
rêve que je voulais tant attendre j'ai
donc poursuivi ma formation et j'avais
la chance d'avoir l'aide de ma famille
malgré la distance et l'aide également
de ma famille en france
c'est ainsi que pendant un cours de
physique déplacement j'ai posé trois
questions successives au profond et au
bout de la troisième il m'a dit des
questions sont pertinentes et là on
dirait que c'était la clé pour moi pour
passer du monde des morts au monde des
vivants
car à la pause le même court quelques
étudiants sont venus vers moi à me
demander d'où tu viens ou est-ce que tu
habites un peu plus curieux sur ma
personne
j'étais content j'avais le sentiment
d'être acceptés
c'est ce sentiment que je recherche
j'avais un sentiment d'existence dans ma
salle et tout à coup je me suis sentie
booster cas pour moi être de plus en
plus bon signifié être de plus en plus
d'intégrer est acceptée j'ai donc
travaillé dur j'ai passé de nombreuses
nuits blanches et j'ai réussi à voir ma
maîtrise à l'université de paris sud en
jeu par la même occasion prouve albert
qu'ils avaient tort d'abord des doutes
sur moi
me voilà donc booster dame a même lancé
cassel réussite pour moi me disait tu te
rapproche de plus en plus de ton rêve
j'ai donc cherché à vouloir faire une
thèse
c'est ainsi que je me suis retrouvé à
sherbrooke à faire une thèse en génie
électrique
ayant conscience que la vie des autres
avaient un impact majeur sur mon estime
personnelle j'avais décidé de travailler
dessus c'est vrai pendant ma thèse j'ai
passé des moments de remise en question
les moments de doute j'ai passé des
moments où j'avais l'impression que mes
émotions aussi est-elle de montagnes
russes mais ce n'était pas du tout à la
vie des autres c'était dû
particulièrement mon sujet de thèse
quand j'avais l'impression de bâtir en
duplex pour était un scène après
j'imagine beaucoup doivent se retrouver
dans ce sentiment
mais heureusement j'avais l'aide de mes
encadreurs leurs encouragements malgré
la longue distance j'avais également
l'aide des membres de ma famille et le
support
j'ai donc pu compléter ma thèse avec des
articles scientifiques clés à l'appui
et aujourd'hui je suis scientifique
ingénieur dans une entreprise de la
place les produits que nous développons
on les retrouve dans le domaine du
médical de la sécurité automobile du
spatial d'un bien d'autres
j'aimerais dit merci aujourd'hui à ce
professeur à l'université paris sud ou
qu'il ait quelques mots m'ont boosté et
ont contribué à la personne que je suis
aujourd'hui
j'aimerais dit merci
à mon feu oncle mon deuxième père car
j'aurais voulu qu'ils soient l'âge ou du
pouvoir le fruit de ses efforts
j'aimerais également dit merci aux
membres de ma famille qui malgré la
distance malgré les nombreuses années
qu'on ne s'est pas vue n'ont pas cessé
de me supporter et de m'encourager
j'aimerais également dit merci au québec
car à travers l'expérience que j'ai
vécue ici j'ai pu le mettre en pratique
gagner de plus en plus confiance en moi
le message que je veux faire passer
aujourd'hui je l'adresse à différents
types de personnes
aux personnes favorisées
j'aimerais que vous prenez conscience
que la vie que vous avez n'est pas
acquise lui nombreux sont ceux là de
niort qui rêvent de la vie que vous avez
aux personnes défavorisées
j'aimerais vous dire de ne pas
considérer l'environnement dans lequel
définit qui vous sourit de rester ouvert
et de ne pas hésiter de saisir la
moindre opportunité que la vie vous
offre
aux personnes qui sont passées par des
situations similaires à la mienne ou
pire encore
j'aimerais vous dire de ne pas vous
refermez sur vous de croire en vous et
de rester ouvert
et à ces personnes qui ont côtoyé des
gens dans ma situation
si vous voyez que dans une entreprise
dans un établissement vous êtes un
ancien et qu'il ya des nouveaux
n'hésitez pas d'aller vers ceux là mêmes
et à vous présenter tiens moi c'est alex
- c'est juliette après le travail ou
après l'établissement nous avons une
activité b tu te joindre à nous
j'espère que ce message servir à de
nombreuses personnes
je vous remercie de m'avoir écouté
[Applaudissements]